From WBEZ in Chicago, it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》节目现在开始，由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。
[MUSIC - TURKEY BASEBALL SONG]
[音乐 - 火鸡棒球之歌]
I suppose it's not enough this time of year that we eat millions of turkeys. Someone also went to the trouble to make up a song about turkeys getting the supernatural power to play baseball. We know they love Thanksgiving. Why wouldn't they enjoy our national pastime? Of course, there is no gobbling in baseball.
我想，在每年的这个时节，光是吃掉数百万只火鸡还不够。还有人费尽心思写了一首歌，讲的是火鸡获得了超自然力量去打棒球。我们知道它们喜欢感恩节，那它们为什么不能享受我们的国民运动呢？当然，棒球比赛里是没有“咯咯”叫声的。
Well, during this time of year-- the beginning of the biggest poultry consumption months in these United States-- it is a tradition here on our radio show to bring you a program full of stories about turkeys, chickens, geese, ducks, fowl of all kinds. And for this year's program we have found stories about poultry and the supernatural, like turkeys playing baseball, except these stories will be true-- the ones you're about to hear.
在每年的这个时候——也就是美国境内禽类消费量最大的月份之初——我们电台有一个传统，就是给大家带来一期关于火鸡、鸡、鹅、鸭以及各种家禽的故事。在今年的节目中，我们找到了一些关于家禽和超自然现象的故事，就像火鸡打棒球那样，不同的是，你们即将听到的这些故事都是真实的。
We have people trying to invest chickens with magical powers. We have birds who may be emissaries from beyond the earth. We have priests using their priestly powers on the poultry industry. And we have chickens lifted heavenward and plucked of their feathers by mysterious forces no one can fathom. It is gods and chickens today on our show. Stay with us.
我们有试图赋予鸡魔法力量的人，有可能是来自地球之外的禽鸟使者，有利用牧师权力影响家禽业的教士，还有被神秘力量带往天堂并拔掉羽毛的鸡。今天的节目主题是：神灵与鸡。请继续收听。
And we begin in a faraway place, an ancient place, the mountains of Pakistan near the border of Afghanistan. Gregory Warner was living there.
故事开始于一个遥远而古老的地方，巴基斯坦边境靠近阿富汗的山区。格雷戈里·华纳曾住在那儿。
The story really begins with JD, an Afghan guy I met in Kabul. The first time I met him, he tried to pretend he was from the States. He sounds really American. Let me play you this voice mail message he left me.
这个故事其实是从JD开始的，一个我在喀布尔认识的阿富汗人。第一次见到他时，他试图假装自己来自美国。他说话听起来真的很像美国人。让我给你们放一段他留给我的语音留言。
Hey Greg. This is JD. I'm calling from Afghanistan, man. Where are you? I sent you an email. Hopefully you'll read it.
嘿，格雷格。我是JD。伙计，我从阿富汗打来电话。你在哪儿？我给你发了封邮件，希望能读到。
Thing is, JD kind of learned his style from the US Marines. For five years, he was an interpreter for them. They also taught him how to shoot and how to dress. They even named him JD, short for Japanese Dude. Japanese, because they said he looked Asian, and dude because he's a dude.
问题是，JD那种说话风格是从美国海军陆战队那儿学来的。有五年时间，他一直是他们的翻译。他们还教他怎么开枪，怎么穿衣。甚至给他取名JD，意为“日本小伙”（Japanese Dude）。叫“日本”是因为他们觉得他长得像亚洲人，“小伙”是因为他确实是个小伙。
Ciao, bitch.
再见，婊子。
End of message.
留言结束。
So when I was asked to go down to the Afghan border and do a story about smugglers, the first thing I did was call up JD and hire him as my translator. He'd stopped working for the Marines by then because he'd gotten married, and his wife said it was too dangerous. He was restless and up for an adventure. A week later we were in Pakistan, driving a Toyota through the streets of his old hometown, Quetta. It's a town popular with smugglers, because it's right on the border of Afghanistan and not too far from Iran. And it's in the middle of the mountains, almost impossible to control.
所以，当有人要求我去阿富汗边境做一个关于走私者的报道时，我做的第一件事就是给JD打电话，雇他当我的翻译。那时候他已经不再为海军陆战队工作了，因为他结婚了，他妻子说那太危险。他当时感到无聊，正想找点冒险。一周后，我们就在巴基斯坦了，开着丰田车穿过他家乡奎达的街道。这是一座深受走私者青睐的城镇，因为它正处于阿富汗边境，离伊朗也不远。而且它位于群山之中，几乎无法管控。
JD wanted me to meet his uncle, an ex-smuggler named Ali. Actually, Ali wasn't really JD's uncle, more like a distant cousin, 20 years older. Back when JD was a little kid, Ali would run operations to Turkey or Malaysia, smuggling heroin, or guns, or illegal aliens. And then a few years ago, Ali announced his retirement. The Americans are here now, he said. The game has changed.
JD想让我见见他叔叔，一个名叫阿里前走私犯。其实，阿里并不是JD的亲叔叔，更像是远房表亲，比他大20岁。早在JD还是个小孩的时候，阿里就会经营通往土耳其或马来西亚的生意，走私海洛因、枪支或非法移民。几年前，阿里宣布退休了。他说，美国人现在在这儿，游戏规则变了。
When I meet Ali, he's grocery shopping in an outdoor market, but in this really commanding way. He stands some four or five feet from each stall, points a long arm at what he wants. He says, "Five kilo rice. Three Pepsi. Two kilo raisin. Send it home to my wife." And then he turns and strides to the next push cart, his loose clothes swishing around him like Laurence Fishburne in The Matrix.
我见到阿里时，他正在露天市场买菜，但那种方式非常有威严。他站在每个摊位四五英尺远的地方，用长长的手臂指向他想要的东西。他说：“五公斤大米。三瓶百事可乐。两公斤葡萄干。送到我家给我妻子。”然后他转身大步走向下一个推车，他宽松的衣服在他周围飘动，就像《黑客帝国》里的劳伦斯·菲什伯恩。
Ali wears dark glasses. And he lost one eye in a gun battle, an injury that looks like it pretty much definitely should have been fatal. I'm thinking that Ali's going to introduce me to some smugglers for my story. But Ali isn't so interested in that. Instead he says he's going to go shoot guns in the mountains with some friends. And we're welcome to tag along.
阿里戴着深色墨镜。他在一场枪战中失去了一只眼睛，那处伤口看起来绝对应该是致命的。我本以为阿里会为我的报道介绍一些走私者给我认识。但阿里对此不太感兴趣。相反，他说他要去山里和几个朋友打枪。我们要是愿意可以跟过去。
Then Ali walks into a store. And he comes out with a cardboard box. On the outside of the box, it's stamped, Pampers. Inside the box is a live chicken. Then Ali closes the box, wraps it up in a scarf, and slings it over shoulder. We follow him and his three scruffy looking friends out of the market, past the last mud houses and into the mountains. That's how my day tracking human smugglers on the edge of a war-torn border turned into a day about a chicken.
接着阿里走进一家商店，出来时手里提着一个纸箱。箱子外面印着“帮宝适”（Pampers）。箱子里装着一只活鸡。阿里合上箱子，用围巾包好，甩在肩上。我们跟着他和三个看起来邋遢的朋友离开了市场，经过最后的几间泥屋，进入了山区。我就这样，在饱受战争蹂躏的边境追踪人口走私犯的一天，变成了一场关于鸡的经历。
"What's with the chicken," I ask JD. And the answer is not what I expect. He tells me that Ali's old friend has been arrested and is in prison. And Ali wants to spring him out. But just in case things go wrong with the jail break, Ali has bought his friend a magic amulet called a taweez. The taweez is supposed to protect whoever wears it from bullets. Before he gives it to his friend, he wants to test the taweez to see if it works, test it on the chicken.
“这鸡是怎么回事？”我问JD。答案出乎我的意料。他告诉我，阿里的老朋友被捕入狱了。阿里想把他救出来。但为了以防越狱出岔子，阿里为他的朋友买了一张名为“塔维兹”（taweez）的魔法护身符。据说这种护身符能保护佩戴者免受子弹伤害。在交给朋友之前，他想测试一下这护身符是否有效，于是就在鸡身上做实验。
"Wait," I say, "we're going to put the magic amulet on the chicken, and then shoot the chicken to see if it's invincible?" "Yeah," JD says, "these guys take religion really seriously."
“等等，”我说，“我们要把这魔法护身符戴在鸡身上，然后开枪打这只鸡，看看它是不是刀枪不入？”“没错，”JD说，“这些人对宗教非常认真。”
We walk up into the mountains. And it's a beautiful morning, sun drenched rocks, dark caves, dry spindly plants over everything. The path is steep. And Ali tells me that back when he was a smuggler, before he'd agree to bring someone through mountains like this, he wouldn't take just anybody. Actually, he'd screen them first for health problems.
我们走进山里。这是一个美丽的早晨，阳光洒在岩石上，黑暗的洞穴，干燥纤细的植物遍布四处。小路很陡。阿里告诉我，当他还是个走私犯时，在同意带人穿过这样的山路之前，他不会带随便什么人。事实上，他会先筛查他们的健康问题。
Heart problem.
心脏问题。
If they had a heart problem, say.
比如他们是否有心脏问题。
Stomach problem.
胃部问题。
We have blood problem.
我们有血液问题。
Blood problem.
血液问题。
We know about all the dark things. We check the person at first.
我们知道所有阴暗的事情。我们首先会检查这个人。
So you give him a physical?
所以你要给他们做体检？
Yeah.
没错。
It seems oddly responsible behavior for a smuggler, though of course he didn't want to get stuck on the side of the mountain with a half-dead guy. I ask Ali if he'd smuggle me. And he says, no. And then he starts to sing.
这对于一个走私犯来说显得异常负责，当然他是不想被困在半山腰上照顾一个半死不活的人。我问阿里他是否会帮我走私。他说，不会。然后他开始唱歌。
[ALI SINGING].
[阿里唱歌]。
And then he leaps on ahead over the rocks with his sack slung on his back like a one-eyed mountains sprite.
然后他像一只独眼的深山精灵一样，背着包在岩石上跳跃前行。
[ALI SINGING]
[阿里唱歌]
After an hour or two, we stop in a little valley with a clump of bushes nearby. Ali puts down the sack. And from his shirt pocket he pulls out the amulet, the taweez. The belief in a taweez is older than Islam. Only in remote, superstitious corners of the world like this do the mullahs deal in this kind of magic. Ali got this one from a mullah. It's nothing fancy, a white scroll the size of a piece of chalk. Ali wraps it in blue plastic and ties it to the chicken's neck.
一两个小时后，我们停在一个长满灌木丛的小山谷里。阿里放下袋子。他从衬衫口袋里掏出那个护身符，那个塔维兹。对塔维兹的信仰比伊斯兰教还要古老。只有在像这样偏远、迷信的世界角落，毛拉才会经营这种魔法。阿里从一个毛拉那里得到了这个东西。它没什么特别，就是一张粉笔大小的白色卷轴。阿里用蓝色塑料把它包起来，系在鸡的脖子上。
The effect does not seem particularly magical. Basically, it looks like a chicken with some garbage tied to its head. But for the experiment it'll do. Ali picks up the bird with both hands, sets it down in some dirt in front of a bush, not too far away either. Imagine a tennis court. If you're standing at the baseline, the chicken is about where the net would be. And then Ali pulls out a handgun from the waistband of his pants. The gun is old looking and blackened with use. And then his three friends pull out their guns. And there is a lot of loading, and cocking, and gun prep.
效果看起来一点也不神奇。基本上，它看起来就像是一只头上绑着垃圾的鸡。但对于实验来说够用了。阿里用双手拿起这只鸟，把它放在灌木丛前的一片泥地上，距离也不算太远。想象一下网球场。如果你站在底线上，那只鸡大约就在球网的位置。接着阿里从裤腰带里掏出一把手枪。那枪看起来很旧，因使用过度而发黑。他的三个朋友也掏出了他们的枪。一阵装弹、上膛和准备工作。
Ali stands up tall. And Ali is tall for an Afghan, about six feet. He holds the gun out with both hands, aims with his one eye, [GUNSHOT] and nothing happens. The next shot [GUNSHOT] hits the dirt right by the chicken's foot, pings up like in the movies. It's really close. And then Ali lifts his gun a third time. And there's just a click. And another click, click. "It's jammed," Ali says. "This never happened before." For a moment, we all take this in.
阿里站得笔直。对于阿富汗人来说，他个子很高，大约六英尺。他双手举枪，用那只独眼瞄准，[枪响]，什么都没发生。下一枪[枪响]，击中了鸡脚旁的泥地，像电影里那样弹了起来。离得非常近。阿里第三次举枪。只听到咔哒一声。又是一声咔哒。阿里说：“卡壳了。这以前从未发生过。”那一刻，我们都沉默了。
Then JD says, "Are you sure?" And he says, "Yeah, I use this gun to kill rabbits." And JD says, "Rabbits?" And Ali says, "Yeah, rabbits." And JD says, "You know the Marines shoot that gun with one hand." And Ali says, "Yeah no, this gun, you have to shoot with two hands." And JD says again, "Well the Marines told me--" And Ali cuts him off saying, "Hey, how much are the Americans spending on the Marines?" And JD takes the hint, and he drops the subject.
然后JD说：“你确定吗？”阿里说：“是的，我平时都用这枪打兔子。”JD说：“兔子？”阿里说：“对，兔子。”JD说：“你知道海军陆战队是用单手射击这把枪的吗？”阿里说：“不，这把枪得用双手射击。”JD又说：“可是海军陆战队告诉我……”阿里打断他道：“嘿，美国人花多少钱在海军陆战队身上？”JD听懂了弦外之音，不再提这个话题。
And then Ali takes his whole gun apart, laying out the pieces on a flat rock. And all this takes a couple of minutes. Meanwhile, the chicken just sits and waits. And I'm going to go out on a limb here on the radio and say that most of sentient creatures caught in gunfire would run.
接着阿里把枪完全拆开，把零件摊在平坦的岩石上。这一切花了几分钟。与此同时，鸡就在那儿坐着等待。我想在电台里多嘴说一句，大多数在枪击中幸存的生物都会跑掉。
And I'm sending little thought waves to the chicken, like, run, run. And this chicken is so just completely overconfident in this taweez.
我在给那只鸡发送微弱的思想波，比如，“快跑，快跑”。而这只鸡对这个塔维兹的自信完全爆棚了。
I think that taweez is working.
我觉得那个塔维兹起作用了。
I say, maybe it's magic. And Ali just shakes his head like I'm crazy, like I'm the gullible one to believe too quickly in this taweez. We haven't finished our test. Maybe it made the gun jam, but Ali's got to be sure. If he's going to give this to his best friend, he's got to know it works.
我说，也许是魔法。阿里只是摇摇头，觉得我疯了，觉得我是那个轻信塔维兹的傻瓜。我们的测试还没结束。也许它让枪卡壳了，但阿里必须确定。如果他要把这个给最好的朋友，他必须知道它是有效的。
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
Finally, Ali fixes whatever was wrong with the gun. The spring got caught on something. He doesn't know why. He reassembles the gun, and then he fires again. [GUNSHOT] And then he fires a fourth time. [GUNSHOT]
最终，阿里修好了枪的问题。弹簧卡在什么东西上了，他也不知道为什么。他重新组装好枪，再次开火。[枪响]，然后他开了第四枪。[枪响]。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[说外语]
And the chicken is still not dead. And Ali looks surprised. "How is this possible," he says. "I still haven't hit it. Really, how is this possible?"
鸡还没死。阿里看起来很惊讶。“这怎么可能，”他说，“我还是没打中它。真的，这怎么可能？”
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[说外语]
Next, Ali's friends each take their turn. [GUNSHOTS] That's three more misses. Ali shoots one last time, [GUNSHOT] and again it pings in the dirt. Ali puts the gun down, and he asks how many bullets we've shot.
接下来，阿里的朋友们轮流开火。[枪响]，又是三次失手。阿里开了最后一次枪，[枪响]，又在地上弹了一下。阿里放下枪，问我们一共开了多少枪。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[说外语]
"OK," he tells everybody, "the thing works." He doesn't say it in a praise God in his infinite wisdom kind of way. He says it like a mechanic closing the hood of a car. OK, it works. And then JD says, "Can I shoot one?" And Ali shrugs, like, sure, let the kid have a go. And he hands him his gun. And JD lifts the gun with one hand like the Marines taught him, straight out in front. And he aims. And he squeezes off a shot. [GUNSHOT]
“行了，”他对大家说，“这玩意儿有用。”他说的语气并不是那种赞美真主保佑的口吻。他说的就像一个修理工关上汽车引擎盖一样：行了，它有用。然后JD说：“我也能开一枪吗？”阿里耸耸肩，像是在说，好吧，让这孩子试试。他把枪递给JD。JD像海军陆战队教的那样，单手举枪，直直地平举。他瞄准了。他扣动了扳机。[枪响]。
And all of a sudden, it looks like some invisible hand came and painted one of the chicken's feathers bright red. And then that red spot gets bigger. We all look at Ali. No one moves, not even the chicken, and it's bleeding. We watch Ali pull out his pocket knife. He strides with long steps over to the chicken, not happy at all. He grabs the chicken by the head and cuts through the blue plastic around its neck with one slice. Then he fishes out the taweez , and he chucks it into a bush. With the next stroke, he slices off the chicken's head.
突然，看起来就像一只看不见的手给鸡的一根羽毛涂上了亮红色。那个红点越来越大。我们都看着阿里。没人动，连那只鸡都没动，它在流血。我们看着阿里掏出折叠刀。他大步走到鸡跟前，看起来很不高兴。他抓住鸡头，一刀割开了脖子上缠着的蓝色塑料。然后他抠出那个塔维兹，把它扔进灌木丛里。随着下一刀，他割下了鸡头。
Later, JD tells me that Ali spent $1,700 on that little scroll. But right now, JD is excited. He's saying, "Where did it hit? Where did I hit him?" And Ali says, "The chest. You hit it in the chest." He digs out the bullet with his knife. And he says, "This bullet is come from the US government." And I'm not sure exactly what he meant by that. But it didn't sound good.
后来，JD告诉我，阿里花了1700美元买了那个小卷轴。但现在，JD很兴奋。他问：“打在哪儿了？我打中它哪儿了？”阿里说：“胸部。你打中了它的胸部。”他用刀把子弹挖了出来。他说：“这颗子弹来自美国政府。”我不确定他这话到底是什么意思，但这听起来不像是好话。
JD, on the other hand, is doing a happy dance, still holding the gun. And then JD starts laughing. Then he says, "Look, he has eaten the heart."
另一边，JD正跳着欢快的舞蹈，手里还拿着枪。然后JD笑了起来，说：“看，它把心脏都吃掉了。”
He just ate the heart?
它把心脏吃了？
Yeah, ow.
对，噢。
Anyway, after that, there isn't much to do but eat the chicken the regular way. We gather brush wood, make a fire in the mouth of the cave, stick the chicken on a stick, and roast it, extra crunchy.
总之，在那之后，除了把鸡按正常方式吃了，也没别的事可做。我们捡来干柴，在洞口生火，把鸡插在棍子上烤，烤得酥脆。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[说外语]
Then Ali chats with guys, like he's trying to forget the whole thing. They don't talk about amulets, or guns, or Marines. Most of the lunch he just makes fun of me. "Look, he's skinnier than I am," he says. "He's so skinny, he'll be dead in 15 days." "Look at him," he says. "He eats too fast."
阿里和大家闲聊，好像试图忘记刚才的一切。他们不谈护身符、枪支或海军陆战队。午餐大部分时间里，他都在取笑我。“看，他比我瘦，”他说，“他太瘦了，15天内就会死。”“看他，”他说，“他吃得太快了。”
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[说外语]
Sitting here in this cave, we can see out for miles. And all up and down the hills there are other clumps of men in robes like us, also sitting around fires cooking lunch, like it has probably been for centuries. It's hard to explain, but out here it's easy to feel like this is all there is and all there ever will be. And Ali's risen up about as high as you can in this world. He went from poor mountain boy, an orphan in a tiny village, to mafia don. And then, all of a sudden someone like JD shows up. And that world doesn't seem like all there is anymore.
坐在洞里，我们可以看到几英里外的地方。沿着山坡，还有其他几拨穿着长袍的男人像我们一样坐在火堆旁吃午饭，就像几个世纪以来一直发生的那样。这很难解释，但在这里，很容易觉得这就是全部，这就是永恒。阿里已经在世界上走到了他所能达到的顶峰。他从一个可怜的山区男孩、一个小村庄的孤儿，变成了黑手党大佬。然后，突然间，像JD这样的人出现了。那个世界似乎不再是唯一的一切。
It's like you start your morning on a mystical pilgrimage with a magic amulet to rescue your best friend. And then, by the end of the afternoon, you learn it wasn't about magic at all. It was just a game of shoot the chicken-- a really expensive game of shoot the chicken-- that you lost to a cocky 23 year old who works with the Americans.
就像你早晨开始了一场神秘的朝圣，带着魔法护身符去拯救最好的朋友。然后到了下午结束时，你发现这根本与魔法无关。这只是一场射鸡游戏——一场极其昂贵的射鸡游戏——你输给了一个为美国人工作的、自大的23岁小伙子。
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[说外语]
Gregory Warner is a reporter based in Philadelphia.
格雷戈里·华纳是一位常驻费城的记者。
Act Two, Winged Migration.
第二幕：迁徙的羽翼。
So it was Saturday, January 10, 2004. And Spalding was in our apartment in New York with our daughter, Marissa, who was 16 at the time, and Theo, who was six.
那天是2004年1月10日，星期六。斯波尔丁和我们16岁的女儿玛丽莎，还有6岁的儿子西奥在纽约的公寓里。
This is Kathie Russo. Her husband was Spalding Gray, who is best known for delivering monologues on stage like "Monster in a Box" and "Swimming to Cambodia." Both those monologues were also filmed as movies. Spalding Gray went missing on January 10, 2004. Witnesses say they saw him on the Staten Island Ferry that night. His body was finally found, pulled out of the East River two months later. Our show today is about birds and the supernatural. And Kathie Russo tells this story about that last night and the days immediately after it. As she said, her husband was with two of their kids that night. She was out that night. They have a third child, Forrest, who was 11 at the time. He was in Sag Harbor, Long Island with friends and a babysitter. They had a house out there too.
我是凯西·鲁索。我的丈夫是斯波尔丁·格雷，他以在舞台上表演独角戏而闻名，如《箱中怪物》和《游泳去柬埔寨》。这两部独角戏后来都被拍成了电影。斯波尔丁·格雷于2004年1月10日失踪。目击者称当晚在斯塔顿岛渡轮上见过他。他的尸体最终在两个月后从东河中被打捞出来。我们今天的节目是关于鸟类和超自然现象的。凯西·鲁索讲述了那个最后的夜晚以及随后的日子。正如她所说，她丈夫那天晚上和两个孩子在一起。她那天晚上出去了。他们还有第三个孩子，福雷斯特，当时11岁。他和朋友及保姆在长岛的萨格港。他们在那里也有个房子。
Spalding had dinner with the kids. And then it got to be about 7:00 PM. He said he was going to meet an old friend. And Marissa goes, "Oh that's fine. You know I'm here. I can watch Theo." And he went out. And about an hour and a half after that, he called to check in on the kids. Theo answered. And he said, how's everything going? He goes, good. He goes, well, I love you very much. And I'll be home soon. And we never saw Spalding again.
斯波尔丁和孩子们吃了晚饭。大约到了晚上7点。他说他要去见一个老朋友。玛丽莎说：“噢，那好，反正我在这儿，我可以照顾西奥。”他出去了。大约一个半小时后，他打电话回来关心孩子们。西奥接了电话。他问：“一切都好吗？”西奥说：“好。”他说：“好吧，我非常爱你们。我很快就回家。”我们再也没见过斯波尔丁。
The next series of events still seem like a blur to me, even five years later. But the first thing I had to do was go report Spalding missing. I did that. And then I decided to send the kids home, back to Sag Harbor to join their brother. So I stayed for two days, did whatever I could, which was pretty much nothing. And after two days, I just decided I'm going back to Sag harbor to join all the kids.
接下来的事情，即使在五年后，对我来说仍然像是一片模糊。我做的第一件事是去报案，报告斯波尔丁失踪。我做了。然后我决定让孩子们回家，回萨格港去和他们的哥哥团聚。所以我留了两天，尽我所能去做任何事，尽管那基本上等于什么都没做。两天后，我决定回到萨格港，去和所有的孩子团聚。
So I'm driving on the Long Island Expressway back to Sag Harbor, and I get a phone call on my cell phone. And it was Theo. And he was all excited. And he said, "Mom, Mom, we came home today from school. And there was a bird, a little bird flying around the island in the kitchen." I said, "And then what did you do next?" He said, "Well we followed the bird. And Marissa followed him into the bathroom. And she tried to calm the bird. And she took a hat, and cupped it over the bird, and captured the bird, and went outside and let him out free."
我正在长岛高速公路上开车回萨格港，手机响了。是西奥。他很兴奋，他说：“妈妈，妈妈，我们今天放学回家，有一只鸟，一只小鸟在厨房的岛台周围飞。”我说：“然后你们做了什么？”他说：“我们就跟着那只鸟。玛丽莎跟着它进了浴室。她试图安抚那只鸟，用帽子扣住它，抓住了它，然后到外面把它放飞了。”
And I was just so dumbfounded and awestruck. The first image that came to my head when he said that there was something-- a bird in particular-- circling over this island, was I thought of Spalding, and how for the last two years he had obsessively circled around that island talking to himself, just circling in total anguish.
我简直惊呆了，敬畏不已。当他说有东西——特别是有一只鸟——在那座岛台上盘旋时，我脑海中出现的第一个画面就是斯波尔丁，在过去两年里，他一直痴迷地在那座岛台上盘旋，自言自语，在极度的痛苦中盘旋。
You see, two years before that, we had been in Ireland celebrating his 60th birthday. And the second day there, Spalding and I were in a horrible car accident. Spalding suffered enormous head trauma. He was never the same. They actually had to put a titanium plate in his head. He was in and out of hospitals for two years after the accident. Doctors prescribed various cocktails of pills for him. Nothing worked, not even the 20 electric shock treatments that he had.
你看，在那之前的两年，我们一直在爱尔兰庆祝他的60岁生日。到那儿的第二天，斯波尔丁和我遭遇了一场可怕的车祸。斯波尔丁头部受了重伤。他再也不一样了。他们不得不在他头上植入一块钛金属板。车祸后的两年里，他出入于各大医院。医生给他开了各种药方。什么都没用，连他做的20次电击治疗也没用。
And the second thought I had when I heard about the bird was, was this a message from Spalding? Was he trying to tell us something? We've never had a bird in our house before. And I remember the Irish have this saying that if you find a bird in your house after someone dies, and it's alive, the person's soul is free. And if you find a dead bird, the person's soul is restless.
当我听说那只鸟的时候，我脑海中的第二个念头是，这是斯波尔丁传来的信息吗？他是在试图告诉我们什么吗？我们家里以前从来没有过鸟。我记得爱尔兰有句谚语：如果有人死后你在家里发现一只鸟，而且它是活的，那人的灵魂就是自由的；如果发现的是死鸟，那人的灵魂就是不安的。
And I remember Spalding-- I'll never forget this story after his mother killed herself 35 years before. His father woke up the very next day. And next to his bed, where his slippers were on the floor, was a dead bird. And that story just stayed with me.
我还记得斯波尔丁——他母亲在35年前自杀后，我永远不会忘记这个故事。他父亲第二天醒来，就在床边放拖鞋的地板上，有一只死鸟。那个故事一直留在我的脑海里。
So that night after the kids went to bed, I went around the house. And I was making sure that another bird could not get into this house, because I wasn't going to take the chance of another bird coming into the house and dying. So I checked all the windows, and I closed all the fireplaces to make sure, to guarantee that there was no way a bird could come into our house.
所以那天晚上孩子们睡着后，我把房子检查了一遍，确保不会再有鸟飞进来，因为我不想冒让另一只鸟飞进屋里死掉的风险。我检查了所有的窗户，封死了所有的壁炉，确保万无一失。
And the next day I was at the dining room table reading the paper. And I looked up, and there was a bird across the table peering at me. And I just couldn't believe what I was seeing. So I yell out to the kids, who are in the other room. And they run in. And the bird takes off, and flies up the stairs. And we all follow it. And it goes into what's our office. And it's perched on top of this window. And I shut the door behind me. And for some reason, I held out my hands, thinking the bird might magically come to my hands. And I go, "Spalding, it's OK. You're safe now. It's OK. Come to me."
第二天，我正坐在餐厅桌子旁看报纸。我抬头一看，桌子对面有一只鸟正盯着我看。我简直不敢相信眼前的一切。我朝在另一个房间的孩子们大喊。他们跑了进来。那只鸟飞走了，顺着楼梯飞上去。我们都跟着它。它进了我们的办公室。它停在那扇窗户顶上。我关上门。不知为何，我伸出双手，以为那只鸟会神奇地飞到我手上。我说：“斯波尔丁，没事的。你现在安全了。没事的，到我这儿来。”
And Forrest and Theo are on the other side of the door going, Mom, why are you calling the bird after dad? And the bird just sat there staring at me. And then it took off. And it flew over my hands. And in between the space in between the door and the floor, it scooted out, went past the boys, flew down the stairs-- and we had already opened up the kitchen doors-- and it flew out the kitchen doors. And it was safe. And it was gone.
福雷斯特和西奥在门那边说：“妈妈，你为什么在那儿叫那只鸟爸爸的名字？”那只鸟就坐在那儿盯着我。然后它飞了起来。它飞过我的手。在门和地板之间的缝隙里，它钻了出去，越过孩子们，飞下楼梯——我们已经打开了厨房的门——它飞出了厨房的门。它很安全。它走了。
The next day, I'm in the kitchen. And Forrest calls out from the TV room. He was watching cartoons. He goes, "Mom, the bird's back. It's at the end of the couch." So before I even go into the room, I open up the kitchen doors, just to make sure we have an exit for the bird. And I run into the family room. And sure enough, there is the bird.
第二天，我在厨房。福雷斯特从电视房喊道。他正在看卡通片。他说：“妈妈，那只鸟又回来了。它在沙发那一头。”所以我还没进房间，就打开了厨房的门，以确保鸟有出口。我跑进家庭室。果不其然，那只鸟就在那儿。
And it has become a drill now. This is the third consecutive day with the bird in our house. And we follow the bird around. And this time it goes through the living room, then it comes back into the kitchen. And I actually got the camera out. And I took a picture of it. And the bird flew out, just like that. It was gone. And two months later, they found Spalding's body in the East River.
这已经成了例行公事了。这是鸟在我们家里的第三天。我们跟着鸟到处走。这一次它穿过客厅，然后回到厨房。我甚至拿出了相机，给它拍了张照片。鸟就这样飞走了。它走了。两个月后，他们发现了斯波尔丁在东河里的尸体。
I think with suicide, in particular, it's a really hard death to digest. There's a lot of guilt. You go back and back. And you get into that mode of, I should have done this. I could have done that. It's a seesaw of guilt and forgiveness.
我觉得自杀这种事，特别是很难消化。有太多的愧疚。你会不断回顾。你会陷入那种“我应该这么做，我本可以那么做”的状态。这是一个愧疚与宽恕的跷跷板。
So last year was my 47th birthday. And I was feeling kind of blue. And I was really missing Spalding. And I went on this bike route that the two of us used to take together. And it ends up by the water. And just before I got to the water, I saw this little, brownish gray bird sitting on the side of the road, just like the one that we had in our house.
去年是我47岁生日。我感到有点忧郁。我真的很想念斯波尔丁。我骑上自行车，沿着我们俩过去常走的那条路。路尽头是水边。就在我到达水边之前，我看到这只灰棕色的小鸟坐在路边，就像我们家里出现的那只一样。
And I passed by it on my bike. I ride pretty fast. But something told me, go back. And I did. And the bird was just sitting there. And I'd get up close to it, and it didn't fly away. So I figured the bird was hurt. And I'm looking at the bird, crouching over it, and this jogger goes by me. And he said, "Oh, that bird was there two hours ago when I started my run."
我骑车经过它。我骑得很快。但有什么东西告诉我，回去看看。我回去了。那只鸟就坐在那儿。我靠近它，它没飞走。所以我想那只鸟受伤了。我看着那只鸟，蹲下身子，一个慢跑者从我身边经过。他说：“噢，那只鸟两个小时前我开始跑步时就在那儿了。”
So I raced back home on my bike. And I went into the house. And I collected a shoe box. And I filled it with grass and bird seed. I got some rubber gloves, and I drove back to where the bird was. And the bird was still there. It was about a mile from my house. And it's just looking up at me. So I thought it was really hurt. And I tried to scoop it into the shoe box. And it just gets up, looks at me, and flies away. There's nothing wrong with it. Wings were fine. I saw it flying off into the distance.
所以我骑车狂奔回家。我进屋找了一个鞋盒。我往里面装满了草和鸟食。我戴上橡胶手套，开车回到鸟所在的地方。鸟还在那儿。离我家大约一英里。它就看着我。所以我以为它真的受伤了。我试图把它铲进鞋盒里。结果它起身看了我一眼，飞走了。它一点事也没有。翅膀很好。我看着它飞向远方。
And I thought-- it just hit me like a ton of bricks right at that moment-- there was nothing I could do to save this innocent little bird, which, in the end, he was fine. He flew away. And there was nothing I could do to save Spalding.
我想——那一刻就像砖头一样重重地击中了我——我无法拯救这只无辜的小鸟，因为它最终很好，它飞走了。而我也无法拯救斯波尔丁。
Kathie Russo. Coming up, when men of God meet men of chickens. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
凯西·鲁索。稍后节目回来，当上帝的子民遇到鸡的子民。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播和国际公共广播，节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week in our program, of course, we choose a theme, and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today, as we enter the period between Thanksgiving and Christmas, the greatest poultry consumption time of the year in our country, we bring you our annual Poultry Slam. Most years on our show that means stories about fowls of all kinds. This year, we're devoting the hour to stories about birds and the supernatural. And specifically, most of these stories seem to be about chickens and God. We have arrived at act three of our program. Act Three, A Pastor and his Flock.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们节目每周都会选择一个主题，带给你们各种关于这个主题的故事。今天，当我们进入感恩节和圣诞节之间的时期——我国禽类消费量最大的时期，我们为您带来一年一度的“禽类大赏”。我们节目往年意味着关于各种禽类的故事。今年，我们将一小时的时间专门用来讲述关于鸟类和超自然现象的故事。具体来说，大部分故事似乎都是关于鸡和上帝的。现在进入节目第三幕：牧师与他的羊群。
Working in a poultry processing plant is probably one of the most unpleasant jobs you can have in this country. It's smelly, it's wet, it's dangerous. Workers get nicked and cut by small knives and scissors. They get carpal tunnel from making the same hand and arm motions over and over. A recent Wake Forest University School of Medicine study of poultry workers found an astonishing 70% of the workers at one North Carolina plant said that they had gotten sick or injured in the previous year at their jobs.
在禽类加工厂工作可能是这个国家最不愉快的职业之一。恶臭、潮湿、危险。工人们会被小刀和剪刀划伤或割伤。他们会因为一遍又一遍重复相同的手部和手臂动作而患上腕管综合征。维克森林大学医学院最近对禽类工人的一项研究发现，北卡罗来纳州一家工厂里高达70%的工人在过去一年中因工作患病或受伤。
The job pays badly too. And as a result, many of the people who do it are immigrants, Latinos mostly. It's also the biggest and fastest growing sector of the meat industry. Nearly a quarter million people work in poultry plants. So you would think this would be a perfect industry for unionization. But barely any poultry plants are represented by a union, especially in the South.
这份工作报酬也很低。结果，从事这份工作的人大多是拉丁裔移民。这也是肉类工业中规模最大、增长最快的部门。近25万人从事禽类加工厂的工作。所以你以为这会是工会化的理想行业。但几乎没有禽类加工厂有工会代表，尤其是在南部。
And that's where the church comes in. The church, especially the Catholic Church, is one of the few institutions doing outreach to poultry workers, giving them space to meet, distributing information about workers' rights, speaking out about bad conditions. And sometimes organizers use the church to intervene with company management in a very, very personal way. Sarah Koenig tells the story of one company called Case Farms and a plant they have in Morganton, North Carolina, in one of the least unionized states in the country.
这就是教会介入的地方。教会，尤其是天主教会，是为数不多向禽类工人伸出援手的机构之一，为他们提供聚会场所，分发关于工人权利的信息，大声疾呼改善糟糕的工作条件。有时，组织者利用教会以非常非常个人的方式干预公司管理。莎拉·科尼格讲述了一家名为Case Farms的公司和他们在北卡罗来纳州摩根顿的工厂的故事，那里是全美工会化程度最低的州之一。
Case Farms in Morganton has been something of a poster plant for labor problems. Worker complaints there were so notorious, so widely publicized, they're partly what prompted the secretary of labor to announce in 1996 that he would investigate the poultry industry. "Sweatshop conditions," he said, "will not be tolerated."
摩根顿的Case Farms一直是劳资问题的典型代表。那里的工人抱怨声名狼藉，广为人知，部分原因是这促使劳工部长在1996年宣布调查禽类行业。他说：“血汗工厂条件绝不容忍。”
In 1995, three young workers got mad about conditions at Case Farms. They were being denied bathroom breaks, they said. And the speed of the production line was dangerously fast. They went to talk to a manager named Ken Wilson. He told them they either had to go back to work or leave the plant. When they didn't move, he had them arrested. "We had no choice but to do what we did," he told The Charlotte Observer .
1995年，三名年轻工人对Case Farms的工作条件感到愤怒。他们说，他们被拒绝上厕所，流水线的速度快得危险。他们去找一位名叫肯·威尔逊的经理谈话。他告诉他们，要么回去工作，要么离开工厂。当他们不走时，他让警察逮捕了他们。“除了这么做，我们别无选择，”他告诉《夏洛特观察家报》。
The workers responded by doing what poultry workers never do, voting in a union. The company fought that union for five years-- never giving it a contract-- until finally, in 2001, the union just pulled out. Four years later in 2005, the workers tried again. And again, one of the central figures in the plant's anti-union campaign was Ken Wilson, the manager who called in the police in 1995. He was director of human resources, but even more than that, he was the public face of the plant.
工人们的反应是做了禽类工人从不做的事：投票加入工会。该公司与工会斗争了五年——始终未签署合同——直到2001年，工会最终撤出。四年后的2005年，工人们再次尝试。而再一次，工厂反工会运动的核心人物之一就是肯·威尔逊，那个1995年召来警察的经理。他当时担任人力资源总监，但不仅如此，他还是工厂的公众形象。
I've had an opportunity to meet with him at the plant itself when we were negotiating about the conditions.
当我们在协商工作条件时，我有机会在工厂见到了他。
Francisco Risso is director of the Western North Carolina Workers' Center, which advocates for poultry workers.
弗朗西斯科·里索是北卡罗来纳州西部工人中心主任，该中心为禽类工人代言。
And I think the last meeting was talking about why they shouldn't wage this anti-union campaign if the workers wanted to have a union. But his position was very clear that the company would be willing to spend any amount of money to keep the union out.
我想最后一次会议是谈论为什么如果工人想要工会，他们就不应该发动这种反工会运动。但他的立场很明确，公司愿意花任何金额的钱来阻止工会。
Was is it overt, like he literally would say, "We are willing to spend any amount of money to keep this union out?" Or was it more oblique than that?
那是公开的吗？比如他真的会说：“我们愿意花任何钱来阻止这个工会？”还是比那更隐晦？
It was pretty overt like that. I would characterize it like what you just said. Believe or it not.
就像你刚才说的那样，非常公开。信不信由你。
Wow, so there was no reading between the lines. It was just--
哇，所以根本不需要猜测。就是……
No, that's pretty much what he said. We're ready to fight this until the end.
不，他基本就是这么说的。我们准备战斗到底。
When I reach Ken Wilson on the phone, he's just as direct with me as he was with Francisco. Here's what he thinks of labor unions. "They're just a competing business. To make money, they need members. And the way they get members is by convincing workers that they're being mistreated."
当我电话联系到肯·威尔逊时，他和我说话就像对弗朗西斯科一样直白。这就是他对工会的看法：“它们只是一个竞争性企业。要赚钱，它们需要会员。而它们获得会员的方式就是说服工人他们受到了虐待。”
So their job is to convince the employees that the company is doing something wrong. I personally feel that the company was looking out for the best interest of the employees. We run a safe plant. So we run a business. They run a business. And at the end of the day, we're going to do what's best for our business.
所以他们的工作是让员工相信公司在做坏事。我个人认为公司是在维护员工的最大利益。我们经营的是一家安全的工厂。我们经营的是一家企业，他们经营的是一家企业。归根结底，我们要为我们的业务做最好的决定。
Knowing Ken Wilson's attitude, Francisco turned to God. He pulled out a tactic that's being used with more and more frequency at workers' centers all over the country. Instead of just using the church to help organize the workers, he would use the church to try to get to management, to get to Ken Wilson.
了解了肯·威尔逊的态度，弗朗西斯科转向了上帝。他采用了一种在全国各地的工人中心越来越频繁使用的策略。与其只利用教会来组织工人，他要利用教会来试图影响管理层，影响肯·威尔逊。
A coalition of tomato pickers did it in south Florida in their fight against Taco Bell. They enlisted the United Methodist Church. The head of Taco Bell's parent company was a member. Cintas commercial laundry workers have done it. It was used at a candle making company in Arkansas. In Texas, the Workers Defense Project has held prayer vigils outside employers' houses in their suburban neighborhoods. They even distributed flyers at an employer's church, telling his fellow congregants he was withholding pay from construction day laborers. They got a restaurant owner's rabbi to intervene on behalf of workers who were being paid below minimum wage.
南佛罗里达州的一个番茄采摘者联盟在与塔可钟（Taco Bell）的斗争中就这样做了。他们寻求了联合卫理公会的帮助。塔可钟母公司的负责人就是该会的成员。Cintas商业洗衣工也这么做过。这还被用在阿肯色州的一家蜡烛制造公司。在得克萨斯州，工人防御项目曾在雇主位于郊区的住宅外举行祈祷守夜。他们甚至在雇主的教会散发传单，告诉他的教友他扣押了建筑零工的工资。他们让餐馆老板的拉比出面，为那些工资低于最低工资的工人争取利益。
It might not sound like the toughest angle to take. But it's one of the last, best tools worker rights advocates have at this point, especially in states down south, where unions have so little influence. Instead of the usual demonstrations and legal challenges, they're playing the faith card, reminding bosses of their moral obligations to their employees. One organizer told me it's more effective than calling in the lawyers. But it doesn't always work, as Francisco discovered at Case Farms when he tried it himself just as the union vote was approaching.
这听起来可能不是最强硬的手段。但在这一点上，这已成为工人权利倡导者最后的有效工具之一，尤其是在南方各州，那里的工会影响甚微。与其进行通常的示威和法律挑战，他们正在打“信仰牌”，提醒老板对员工的道德义务。一位组织者告诉我，这比请律师更有效。但并非总是有效，正如弗朗西斯科在Case Farms发现的那样，他在工会投票即将到来时尝试了这一招。
Somewhere around that time, I guess, we found out that he was a member of the local Episcopal church. My wife attended church there. And so through her I knew the pastor there, the priest, Revered Walker. And so I found out if he knew Ken, what the relationship was like. And then I asked him if he would be willing to speak with Ken and talk about what the church says about workers and about how we're supposed to treat the poor.
就在那时左右，我想，我们发现他是当地圣公会教会的成员。我妻子在那儿做礼拜。通过她，我认识了那儿的牧师，沃克牧师。所以我打听了他是否认识肯，他们的关系如何。然后我问他是否愿意找肯谈谈，谈谈教会关于工人以及我们应该如何对待穷人的教导。
Why did you think an appeal to his faith, or his belief in the Bible, or something would be more effective than a pocketbook argument?
为什么你认为诉诸他的信仰，或他对比布的信仰，会比单纯的经济账更有效？
I think what I was hoping for was that he would be open to having a good discussion with the priest, and maybe to really faithfully reflect on what the situation was, and reflect on what the faith had to say about it. Not so much that he would be shamed into doing something, but that his heart would really be touched. And he would see how he's supposed to act.
我想我希望的是他能敞开心扉与牧师进行良好的讨论，也许能真正虔诚地反思情况，并反思信仰对此的看法。与其说羞辱他去做什么，不如说触动他的内心。让他看到他应该如何行事。
Was it also partly that just, frankly, the pocketbook argument wasn't working?
是否也有一部分原因是，坦率地说，经济账根本没起作用？
Yeah.
是的。
So from your point of view, it's like, well what else can you appeal to, really?
所以从你的角度来看，就像是，还能诉诸什么呢，真的？
Uh-huh. I think that that's the basic-- that's the kind of thing that if we had anything in common with our enemy, with our adversary in this, that it was that, that you have a shared, proclaimed faith.
嗯，我想如果说我们和敌人、和对手有什么共同点，那就是，你们都有一个共同宣称的信仰。
My name is Bruce Walker, and I am rector of Grace Episcopal Church in Morganton, North Carolina.
我是布鲁斯·沃克，我是北卡罗来纳州摩根顿恩典圣公会教会的牧师。
Bruce Walker had come to town three years earlier knowing nothing of Case Farms or the problems there. No more than one or two Case Farms workers attended his church, which was mostly white and middle class. But Father Walker did know Ken Wilson. And he thought he was a nice man. When one of Ken's co-workers was killed in a car accident, Ken had asked Father Walker to come to the plant and do some grief counseling. And it had gone well. Through Francisco though, Father Walker was learning about the safety complaints at Case Farms. And he was sympathetic. Then Francisco asked him to come to the plant on the day of the union vote to talk to Ken. Father Walker was a little hesitant at first.
布鲁斯·沃克三年前来到镇上时，对Case Farms及其问题一无所知。他的教会里只有一两个Case Farms的工人，大多数是白人和中产阶级。但沃克牧师确实认识肯·威尔逊。他觉得他是个好人。当肯的一位同事在车祸中丧生时，肯曾请沃克牧师去工厂做一些哀伤辅导，效果不错。然而，通过弗朗西斯科，沃克牧师得知了Case Farms的安全投诉，并表示同情。然后弗朗西斯科请他在工会投票当天去工厂和肯谈谈。沃克牧师起初有些犹豫。
I wasn't naive. I knew that doing that, the possibility of it not going well, turning out well, was there. And there would be the possibility of alienation down the road. And I didn't want that. And when I went that morning, it was pretty early. I saw Francisco. He introduced me to some of his co-workers and friends.
我并不天真。我知道这样做，结果不好的可能性是存在的。而且日后可能会产生隔阂。我不希望那样。那天早上去的时候，还很早。我看到了弗朗西斯科。他把我介绍给了一些工友和朋友。
And I did see Ken there. And I went over and spoke to Ken, and told him I was there to be supportive of this process. And I did suggest to him that if I could be helpful in mediation, I would be glad to do that.
我确实在那儿看到了肯。我走过去和肯说话，告诉他我来是为了支持这个过程。我确实建议他，如果我能在调解中提供帮助，我会很乐意。
And he had told me before that he was interested too in the rights of the workers and their safety. And I told Ken, I said, I don't see there's any difference in that idea. I think everybody here wants the workers to have a safe place. I don't know that we have the same road or the same method of doing that. But he listened. And he was nice enough with me. But I could tell he was flush. All the signs were there that I 'd stepped into it big time. I got the distinct feeling that he wished I had not been there that day.
他之前也告诉我，他同样关心工人的权利和安全。我告诉肯，我说，我不认为这有什么区别。我想这里每个人都希望工人们有一个安全的地方。我不知道我们是否有相同的路径或相同的方法来实现这一点。但他听了，对我还算客气。但我看得出来他面露愠色。所有的迹象表明我闯大祸了。我有一种明显的感觉，他希望那天我不曾出现在那里。
I was walking out the front door of our plant, going across the street. We have another small office across the street.
我正走出我们工厂的前门，穿过街道。我们在街对面还有另一个小办公室。
Ken Wilson remembers the whole thing a little differently. It was a more casual meeting.
肯·威尔逊对整件事的记忆有点不同。那是一次更随意的会面。
And he was walking down the street. And we just happened to run into one another.
他正走在街上，我们刚好撞见了。
Were you surprised to see him there?
看到他你惊讶吗？
Oh yeah.
噢，当然。
Ken also remembers their conversation a little differently. He says Father Walker told him he had mixed feelings about being there that day, since he had parishioners on both sides of the union issue, Ken and another guy. And that he was there to support both of them.
肯对他们的谈话记忆也有些不同。他说沃克牧师告诉他，那天他来到这里心情复杂，因为他两边的会众都有，肯和另外一个人。他说他来是为了支持他们双方。
He said that he would be willing to mediate or to do what he could to bring the groups together. And of course I explained to him that it was an election. And in an election, you would have a winner and a loser. And at the end of the day, it would be left up to our employees to make that decision.
他说他愿意调解或尽他所能将双方聚在一起。当然，我向他解释说这是一场选举。而在选举中，你会有赢家和输家。归根结底，决定权在于我们的员工。
It's not so much what Father Walker said that day that bothered Ken. It's how the whole thing looked.
那天沃克牧师说的话并没有太困扰肯，真正困扰的是整件事看起来像什么。
Under the circumstances, I would rather that he not had been there. But I guess the only word that would describe it would be disappointed.
在这种情况下，我宁愿他没在那儿。但我猜能描述它的词就是失望。
What was disappointing about it?
失望的是什么？
His presence.
他的出现。
Did you read it as in support of the of the union?
你解读为这是在支持工会吗？
I would think from anyone else's perspective, they probably would have felt so, yes.
我想从任何人的角度来看，他们可能都会这么觉得，是的。
Oh, you're saying that the way it looked was as if your priest had come in favor of the union.
噢，你是说看起来好像你的牧师站在了工会那边。
Exactly.
正是。
I see. It doesn't look great for for a manager's priest to be showing up.
我明白了。对于经理的牧师出现在那里，确实看起来不太好。
[LAUGHING] Kind of a poor reflection on the manager, isn't it? Maybe I should up my tithe, don't you think?
[笑] 对经理来说是个糟糕的反映，不是吗？也许我应该增加什一税，你不觉得吗？
Did you say up your tithe?
你说增加什一税？
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, right. Well precisely, precisely. Do you think the church-- is there a Christian argument to be made that, look we need to fight for the poor and for human rights. And we need to be involved with this stuff. And it is our place to show up and do this work?
是的，没错。好吧，正是，正是。你认为教会——是否存在一种基督教的论点，即我们必须为穷人和人权而战。我们需要参与这些事情。这理应是我们去出现并做这些工作的地方？
The church has a right to do as it sees fit. My only request from any church group is to make sure they get all their facts before they take a position.
教会有权做它认为合适的事情。我向任何教会团体的唯一请求就是，在他们表态之前，确保他们掌握了所有事实。
From Ken's perspective, the facts were these. The workers voted to keep the union out that day, 296 to 225. From the perspective of those who wanted the union though, the no vote was the result of a long and intimidating anti-union campaign.
从肯的角度来看，事实如下：工人们那天投票决定让工会拒之门外，296票对225票。然而从那些想要工会的人的角度来看，反对票是一场长期且恐吓性的反工会运动的结果。
Father Walker says his relationship with Ken Wilson pretty much ended that same day. He got the feeling that Ken just didn't think it was any of his business. Here's Father Walker.
沃克牧师说他和肯·威尔逊的关系基本就在那一天结束了。他觉得肯认为这根本不关他的事。沃克牧师说：
Perhaps he felt that my role was about more traditional things, like conducting worship on Sunday morning and visiting the sick. And as far as engaging in anything that was involved in injustice, that I was out of my realm. That's the feeling I got. And that's more of a feeling. And I think he alluded to kind of, what are you doing here? This isn't where you should be.
也许他觉得我的角色是关于更传统的事情，比如周日上午主持崇拜和探访病人。至于参与任何涉及不公正的事情，我越界了。这就是我的感觉。这更多是一种感觉。我想他暗指了类似：你在这儿干什么？这不该是你待的地方。
But I see just the opposite. I think that's the way a lot of people feel these days about clergy. But at the same time, as a Christian I look at Jesus as an example of what we're to be about. If you note through scripture, most of the time, Jesus is out on the road, so to speak, preaching from a mountaintop or by the seashore, out in the community going from one place to the next. Rarely is he contained within a building. And maybe that's-- as people's guide, we need to be outside our confines, more out into the world.
但我看到的恰恰相反。我想如今很多人对教职人员都有这种感觉。但与此同时，作为基督徒，我以耶稣为榜样，看待我们该做什么。如果你注意看圣经，大多数时候，耶稣都在路上，可以说，在山顶或海边布道，深入社区，从一个地方走到另一个地方。他很少被局限在建筑内。也许这就是——作为人们的向导，我们需要走出局限，更多地走向世界。
Ken Wilson says he doesn't remember quitting Grace Church exactly, at least not consciously. But that's how it seemed to Father Walker. He called Ken a couple of times after that, wrote him a reconciling note. But he says he never really saw him back in church. In any case, about a year after the union vote, the Wilsons moved to the other side of the state, near Raleigh.
肯·威尔逊说他不记得确切地退出了恩典教会，至少不是有意识的。但在沃克牧师看来确实如此。那之后他给肯打了几个电话，写了一张和解的字条，但他说再也没见他回教会。无论如何，工会投票一年后，威尔逊一家搬到了州的那一边，靠近罗利。
Did you-- afterwards, considering it didn't seem to actually go so well-- did you regret talking to him? Did you regret taking that step?
你之后——考虑到事情似乎并没有进展得那么好——你后悔找他了吗？你后悔迈出那一步吗？
Maybe a little at first, but not now. And if I have a regret, probably it's that I didn't do more to be helpful in that situation. I didn't go back to him the next day or the following day, and say, we really need to talk. Or maybe get with Francisco again, and say, how are you feeling, and how can I help you more? If I have any regrets, it's probably that I didn't do enough.
起初可能有一点，但现在没有了。如果有遗憾，可能是因为我没有做更多的事情来在那情况下提供帮助。我没有在第二天或接下来的几天里回去找他，说，我们真的需要谈谈。或者也许再找弗朗西斯科，说，你感觉如何，我能如何更多地帮你？如果说有什么遗憾，可能就是我做得不够。
Francisco doesn't think Father Walker failed. Maybe he didn't change Ken's mind that day. But who knows? In a year or two it could sink in. The Case Farms fight is still going on. The workers haven't given up. They're still talking about unionizing. Right now they say the company is trying to fire about 100 employees unfairly, including many experienced workers, in order to deny them benefits, or just get rid of people who tend to complain and organize.
弗朗西斯科不觉得沃克牧师失败了。也许他那天没改变肯的想法。但谁知道呢？一两年内它可能会沉淀下来。Case Farms的斗争仍在继续。工人们没有放弃。他们仍在谈论工会化。现在他们说公司正试图不公平地解雇约100名员工，包括许多有经验的工人，以剥夺他们的福利，或者仅仅是为了摆脱那些倾向于抱怨和组织的人。
Francisco and a church deacon met with two newer managers at the plant recently to talk about the firings, but they didn't get anywhere. So now Francisco is trying to find out where these managers go to church to see if their priests will talk to them. Workers at Case Farms are pretty pessimistic at the moment, Francisco says. And it's easy to see why. But he himself isn't. He believes people are basically good, which means the union-busting manager is always just a conversation away from conversion.
弗朗西斯科和一位教会执事最近与工厂的两名新经理见了面，谈论解雇问题，但一无所获。所以现在弗朗西斯科正试图查明这些经理去哪儿做礼拜，看看他们的牧师是否会和他们谈谈。弗朗西斯科说，Case Farms的工人们目前相当悲观。原因显而易见。但他本人并不悲观。他相信人本质上是善良的，这意味着工会破坏者经理离“转化”始终只是一次谈话的距离。
Christianity is full of examples like that, he says. Think of Saul, who persecuted Christians until a vision of Jesus blinded him on the road to Damascus. After that, he was Paul the Apostle.
他说，基督教里充满了这样的例子。想想扫罗，他迫害基督徒直到在去大马士革的路上被耶稣的异象致盲。在那之后，他成了使徒保罗。
Sarah Koenig. She's one of the producers of our program.
莎拉·科尼格。她是本节目的制作人之一。
Act Four, Twistery Mystery. We now turn to Wayne Curtis, who has been puzzling over an unexplained phenomenon involving chickens, a riddle that is nearly two centuries old.
第四幕：龙卷风之谜。现在转向韦恩·柯蒂斯，他一直在研究一个涉及鸡的未解现象，这是一个近两个世纪之久的谜题。
I was researching tornadoes, leafing through 19th century newspaper accounts of the havoc they caused. And I found it was hard not to notice the sheer amount of poultry involved. It's mostly chickens, sometimes turkeys, rarely geese. The birds typically show up about 2/3 of the way into an article, after the description of entire barns being hoovered up into the sky, or bits of straw piercing a fence post. Sometimes whole flocks are ingested by the twister, and scattered lifelessly across the landscape like large snowflakes. But more often it's just a few birds. And these often attract the attention of newspapers for one reason. They're alive and clucking, but plucked cleaned as Butterballs.
我当时在研究龙卷风，翻阅19世纪报纸关于它们造成破坏的报道。我发现很难不注意到其中涉及的禽类数量之巨大。主要是鸡，有时是火鸡，很少有鹅。鸟儿通常出现在文章的2/3处，在描述整个谷仓被吸入天空，或碎草刺穿栅栏柱之后。有时整个群鸟被龙卷风吞噬，像大雪花一样毫无生气地散落在地表。但更多时候只是几只鸟。这些鸟往往因一个原因吸引了报纸的注意：它们活着且咯咯作响，却像买来的净膛鸡一样被拔得干干净净。
When I came upon the first reference to a tornado-plucked chicken, I jotted it down as a freak occurrence. But then I came across another, and another. It turns out newspapers are filled with dozens-- if not hundreds-- of similar reports of naked poultry. A few examples. Rhode Island 1838, chickens, quote, "were seen walking about in all their naked simplicity after the spout had passed on." Missouri 1877, quote, "feathers were blown from chickens." Iowa 1893, quote "chickens were found alive and completely stripped of their feathers." And the year 1878 was a notably harsh one for poultry. In North Carolina, nearly 1,200 chickens were sucked into the sky and quote, "left free of feathers and ready for the stew pot."
当我偶然发现关于龙卷风拔鸡毛的第一条记录时，我把它记为一种怪异现象。但后来我又看到了第二条，第三条。事实证明，报纸上充斥着数十甚至数百篇关于裸体禽类的类似报道。举几个例子。1838年罗德岛州，鸡，“在龙卷风过后被看到走动，赤条条的”。1877年密苏里州，“羽毛从鸡身上被吹走”。1893年爱荷华州，“鸡活着被发现，羽毛被完全剥除”。1878年对于禽类来说是格外严酷的一年。在北卡罗来纳州，近1200只鸡被吸入空中，“被拔光羽毛，可以下锅炖了”。
If you were living in the 19th century and you wondered what a vengeful God looked like, a tornado would have been a pretty good representation. It had that whole finger of death thing going on, descending from the sky and randomly smiting and destroying. But this was a God given to occasional whimsy. The tornado would take a house and reduce it to splinters, but deposit a woman, still in a bathtub, atop a tree. Or it would take a chicken, strip it of its feathers, and set it free.
如果你生活在19世纪，想知道复仇的上帝长什么样，龙卷风会是一个非常好的表现形式。它有一种死亡之指降临天空，随机降下惩罚和破坏的感觉。但这是上帝偶然的奇想。龙卷风会把房子夷为平地，却把一个还在浴缸里的女人扔到树顶上。或者它会带走一只鸡，拔光它的羽毛，然后放它自由。
In 1842, a pioneering meteorologist in Ohio named Elias Loomis decided that naked chickens were not just a curiosity but a key that would unlock the secrets of tornadoes. At the time, virtually nothing was known about tornadoes, what caused them, how fast their winds could go, what was going on inside of them. Loomis figured that if he could calculate the speed at which wind blew off a chicken's feathers, he would have the first scientific estimate of the wind speed inside a tornado.
1842年，俄亥俄州的一位先驱气象学家伊莱亚斯·卢米斯认定，光秃秃的鸡不仅仅是个好奇心，还是开启龙卷风秘密的钥匙。当时，关于龙卷风几乎一无所知：是什么导致了它们，它们的风速有多快，里面发生了什么。卢米斯推算，如果他能计算出风吹掉鸡毛的速度，他就能得到龙卷风内部风速的第一个科学估计。
So he loaded a freshly killed chicken into a six pound cannon, pointed the gun skyward, lit the fuse and stood back. The cannon roared. The feathers soared to a height of 20 or 30 feet at a velocity Loomis estimated to be 341 miles per hour. He carefully examined the evidence and found the feathers had indeed been plucked clean. The only problem was with the chicken. It had been blown into small fragments quote, "only a part of which could be found," Loomis wrote. And so, no scientific conclusions could be drawn.
于是他把一只刚杀的鸡装进一门六磅重的炮里，炮口朝天，点燃导火索，往后退。大炮轰鸣，羽毛飞向了20到30英尺的高度，卢米斯估计其速度为每小时341英里。他仔细检查了证据，发现羽毛确实被拔得干干净净。唯一的问题是鸡，它被炸成了细小的碎片，卢米斯写道，“只能找到一部分”。因此，无法得出任何科学结论。
Loomis didn't give up on chickens. He still believed they held some of the secrets to tornadoes. Another theory floating around was that the funnel of a tornado contained a pocket of astonishingly low barometric pressure. Maybe, Loomis thought, when a chicken was sucked into a tornado, the air in its hollow quills expanded so rapidly that the feathers basically exploded out of the chicken's skin. To test this, Loomis put dead chickens in vacuum jars, then sucked out the air. The experiment was no more conclusive than the cannon. The feathers remained unmoved, still attached to limp chickens.
卢米斯没有放弃鸡。他仍然相信它们掌握着龙卷风的一些秘密。另一个流传的理论是，龙卷风的漏斗含有令人惊讶的低气压袋。卢米斯心想，也许当一只鸡被吸入龙卷风时，它空心羽轴里的空气膨胀得如此之快，以至于羽毛基本上从鸡皮里爆炸了出来。为了测试这一点，卢米斯把死鸡放进真空罐里，然后抽干空气。实验结果并不比大炮更有说服力。羽毛纹丝不动，仍然附着在软塌塌的鸡身上。
What Loomis did next was excellent news for the chickens of Ohio. He abandoned the study of tornadoes, and went on to explore theories of the aurora borealis.
卢米斯接下来所做的对于俄亥俄州的鸡来说是个好消息：他放弃了龙卷风研究，转而探索极光理论。
After that, weather researchers pretty much ignored poultry for more than a century. Then, in the 1970s, there was a minor eruption of renewed interest in tornado-plucked chickens. In part, we can thank the Atomic Energy Commission for this. They wanted to make sure that nuclear reactors were being designed to withstand the worst possible tornado. To do this, they assembled a team of civil engineers and meteorologists from Texas Tech to figure out what exactly that maximum possible tornado might be. The team decided that it would be prudent to chase down stray tornado myths-- no matter how bizarre-- to ensure that nothing inexplicable would slip by.
那之后，气象研究人员基本忽视了禽类一个多世纪。直到20世纪70年代，对龙卷风拔鸡毛的兴趣又产生了一次小规模的爆发。在某种程度上，这要归功于原子能委员会。他们想确保核反应堆的设计能够经受住最严重的龙卷风。为此，他们召集了来自德克萨斯理工大学的一组土木工程师和气象学家，以查明那种“最大可能龙卷风”到底是什么样的。该团队决定，谨慎的做法是追查 stray 龙卷风神话——无论多么离奇——以确保没有任何不可解释的事情被漏掉。
Where did the chickens fit in? One of the myths they set out to disprove was that tornadoes could produce bizarrely high wind speeds-- as much as 800 miles per hour-- and that it was these high wind speeds that removed feathers from chickens. But the team quickly discarded this idea when they learned that chickens could start to lose their feathers in winds as little as 30 miles per hour.
鸡怎么适应这一切的？他们着手驳斥的神话之一是，龙卷风会产生离奇的高风速——高达每小时800英里——正是这些高风速去除了鸡的羽毛。但当团队了解到鸡在风速仅为每小时30英里时就开始掉羽毛，他们很快丢弃了这个想法。
Then in 1975, an atmospheric scientist named Bernard Vonnegut-- the brother of writer Kurt Vonnegut-- introduced a new theory about why chickens lose their feathers during tornadoes, fear. In other words, when chickens got scared, their feathers loosened. In a paper he published entitled "Chicken Plucking as Measure of Tornado Wind Speed," he said quote, "possibly this may be a mechanism for survival, leaving a predator with only a mouthful of feathers and permitting the bird to escape."
然后在1975年，一位名叫伯纳德·冯内古特的大气科学家——作家库尔特·冯内古特的兄弟——引入了一个新理论，解释为什么鸡在龙卷风中会掉毛：恐惧。换句话说，当鸡受惊时，它们的羽毛会变松。在题为《作为龙卷风风速测量的拔鸡毛》的论文中，他写道：“这可能是一种生存机制，给捕食者留下一嘴羽毛，从而允许鸟类逃脱。”
It was an elegant theory. And it became a widely accepted answer to the historic question about de-feathered chickens.
这是一个优雅的理论。它成了关于去毛鸡历史性问题的广泛接受的答案。
As a theory, it has just one downside. There doesn't seem to be a single person in the business of studying poultry who finds it even vaguely plausible. Or I couldn't find them anyway. Wayne Kuenzel is with the Center of Excellence for Poultry Science at the University of Arkansas. And he told me that the chicken industry has spent huge sums trying to figure out how to pluck chickens quickly and efficiently. If all it took was a good fright, poultry processing plants would be filled with animatronic coyotes. Plus, he pointed out, from the perspective of evolution, it doesn't make much sense for a chicken to lose its flight feathers when trying to escape predators.
作为理论，它只有一个缺点。禽类研究领域似乎没有一个人觉得它哪怕有一点可信度。或者至少我没找到。韦恩·昆泽尔在阿肯色大学禽类科学卓越中心。他告诉我，禽类行业花费巨资试图研究如何快速高效地拔鸡毛。如果只要受惊就能做到，禽类加工厂早就塞满了动画土狼。此外，他指出，从进化的角度来看，鸡在试图逃避捕食者时失去飞行羽毛并不合理。
So basically, we're back to where we were about 1840. We still don't know why some chickens ended up running around without their feathers after tornadoes. The naked chickens have had their encounter with science. And the naked chickens have pretty much won.
所以基本上，我们回到了1840年左右的状态。我们仍然不知道为什么有些鸡在龙卷风过后会光秃秃地跑来跑去。裸体的鸡已经与科学进行了碰撞。而裸体的鸡基本赢了。
Wayne Curtis is a writer in New Orleans. He is the author most recently of And a Bottle of Rum: A History of the New World in Ten Cocktails."
韦恩·柯蒂斯是新奥尔良的一位作家。他最近的作品是《朗姆酒一瓶：以十种鸡尾酒书写新世界历史》。
Act Five, Chicken Coop for the Soul. Shalom Auslander grew up as an Orthodox Jew, attending religious school in a community of Orthodox Jews. And he has this story to end this show about supernatural forces and chickens.
第五幕：灵魂鸡舍。沙洛姆·奥斯兰德在正统犹太教社区长大，就读宗教学校。他有这个故事来结束这个关于超自然力量和鸡的节目。
When Yankel Morgenstern died and went to heaven, he was surprised to find that God was a large chicken. The chicken was about 30 feet tall and spoke perfect English. He stood before a glimmering, eternal coop made of chicken wire of shimmering gold. And behold, inside, a nest of diamonds. "No freaking way," said Morgenstern. "You know," said Chicken, "that's the first thing everyone says when they meet me. 'No freaking way.' How does that make me feel?"
当扬克尔·摩根斯特恩死后去到天堂，他很惊讶地发现上帝是一只大鸡。这只鸡大约30英尺高，说一口地道的英语。他站在一个由闪烁金色的鸡丝网制成的闪耀永恒鸡舍前。瞧，里面有一个钻石筑成的窝。“没可能，”摩根斯特恩说。“你知道吗，”鸡说，“这是每个人见我第一面时说的第一句话。‘没可能’。这让我感觉如何？”
Morgenstern threw himself at Chicken's feet, kissing his enormous, holy claws. "Hear O Israel, the Lord is your God, the Lord is one," Morgenstern cried out. Chicken stepped back and shrugged. "Eh," he said, bobbing his enormous head. "What?" Asked Morgenstern. "I don't know. What's that supposed to do for me? Hear O Israel?" he asked. "How's it go again?" "It's Shema," Morgenstern said with hesitation, "The prayer. We say it twice a day."
摩根斯特恩跪倒在鸡的脚下，亲吻他巨大而神圣的爪子。“听着，以色列啊，耶和华是我们的上帝，耶和华是独一的，”摩根斯特恩大声喊道。鸡往后退并耸了耸肩。“呃，”他说，摆动着巨大的脑袋。“什么？”摩根斯特恩问。“我不知道。那能为我做什么？以色列啊？”他问。“那祷告怎么念来着？”“那是《示马》，”摩根斯特恩犹豫着说，“那是祈祷文。我们每天说两次。”
Chicken stomped around in a circle before settling down in his holy nest of nests. "Yeah," he said, "I know. I've been hearing it for years. Still not sure what it means though. Hero Israel. Hero, like the sandwich?" "Not hero like the sandwich," snapped Morgenstern. He stood up, clutching his black felt hat in his hand. "Hear O Israel. It means that you are one, that you are the only, you know, God."
鸡在圈子里跺着脚，然后在神圣的窝里安定下来。“是的，”他说，“我知道。我已经听了很多年了。但还是不确定它意味着什么。以色列英雄（Hero Israel）。英雄，像那个三明治？”“不是那个英雄三明治，”摩根斯特恩尖声说。他站起来，手里攥着黑毡帽。“听着，以色列。它的意思是你是独一的，你是唯一的，你知道，上帝。”
That last word didn't come easily. "Of course I am," said Chicken. "Do you see any other chickens around here? Hey Gabe. Gabe," called Chicken. "Is it Hero Israel, like the sandwich, or Hear O Israel?"
最后一个词说得不容易。“我当然是，”鸡说。“你在这儿看到别的鸡了吗？嘿，盖比。盖比，”鸡叫道。“是‘以色列英雄’像三明治那样，还是‘听着，以色列’？”
A stocky old man appeared from the clouds. He wore a pair of dirty Carhartt overalls and smoked a cigarette. "It's hero like the sandwich sir. You are quite correct." He turned his head sharply to Morgenstern. "Morgenstern?" he asked. "Yes." "Follow me." "Gabe," he said extending his hand to Morgenstern as they walked through the nothingness to the nowhere.
一个结实的老人从云层中出现。他穿着一身肮脏的卡哈特（Carhartt）背带裤，抽着烟。“是英雄像三明治那样，长官。你是完全正确的。”他猛地转头看向摩根斯特恩。“摩根斯特恩？”他问。“是的。”“跟我来。”“盖比，”他伸出手对摩根斯特恩说，一边走向虚无。“像加百列（Gabriel），对吧？”摩根斯特恩问。“对，”盖比说，“我算是这儿的总牧场管理员。我确保鸡有足够的饲料和水。我清理他的鸡舍。你知道，一般性维护。”“鸡不能自己创造食物吗？”摩根斯特恩问。“不是‘鸡’（Chicken），”盖比说，“是‘鸡’（Chicken）。不，他不能自己创造食物。他是一只鸡。”
"As in Gabriel, right?" asked Morgenstern. "Right," said Gabe. "I'm sort of the head ranch hand around here. I make sure Chicken has enough feed and water. I clean his coop. You know, general maintenance." "Couldn't the Chicken just create his own food?" asked Morgenstern. "Not the Chicken," said Gabe, "just Chicken. And no he can't create his own food. He's a chicken."
摩根斯特恩问盖比他要带他去哪儿。“哪儿也不去，”他说，“这就是我们在这儿做的事。无论你走到哪儿，你就在那儿。”“天哪，”摩根斯特恩喊道，“你是佛教徒。该死，我早知道佛教徒是对的。总是那么快乐和平静。”“他不是佛教徒，”盖比打断道。他停下来点了一支万宝路红烟。“他是一只鸡。”
Morgenstern asked Gabe where he was taking him. "Nowhere," he said, "this is what we do here. Wherever you go, there you are." "Christ," cried Morgenstern, "you're Buddhist. Damn, I knew the Buddhists were right. Always so happy and peaceful." "He's not a Buddhist," interrupted Gabe. He paused to light a cigarette, Marlboro Reds. "He's a chicken."
“我需要回到地球，”摩根斯特恩脱口而出。“地球，为什么？”摩根斯特恩转过身面对盖比。“让我告诉他们，盖比。拜托，让我告诉我的家人，只告诉我的家人，盖比。他是一只鸡，不是海什姆（Hashem），不是唯一的真正审判者，不是阿多奈（Adonai），不是万能的上帝。噢，我浪费的那些年。让我告诉他们，这样他们就不必像我那样跳进那些圈套里，试图取悦某个在天上的疯狂父亲。九个孩子，盖比。他们本应该拥有九个完整、快乐、无忧无虑的生命。让他们在周六开车。让他们吃培根。让他们去红龙虾餐厅买午餐特价。麦当劳，盖比。你这儿有炸薯条吗？有吗？带奶酪的汉堡是什么味道？拜托，让我告诉他们，盖比。”
"I need to go back to Earth," Morgenstern blurted out. "Earth, why?" Morgenstern turned to face Gabe. "Let me tell them, Gabe. Please, let me tell my family, just my family, Gabe. He's a chicken, not Hashem, the one true judge, not Adonai, the Lord Almighty. Oh, the years I wasted. Let me tell them so they don't have to jump through the hoops I did, trying to please some maniacal father who art in heaven. Nine children, Gabe. Nine full, happy, worry-free lives they should have. Let them drive on Saturday. Let them eat bacon. Let them get the lunch special at Red Lobster. McDonald's, Gabe. Do you have any of those fries up here? Do you? What does a hamburger with cheese taste like? Please, let me tell them Gabe."
盖比深吸了一口烟，摇了摇头。“他们不会听的，”他说，“我自己尝试告诉过几个。但你想回地球？去吧。回地球去吧。”摩根斯特恩紧紧拥抱了盖比。“你不必向那只鸡请示吗？”“不是那只鸡，”盖比说，“是鸡。不，我不需要。那只鸡不在乎任何方式。”他弹掉烟蒂。“他早晨得到饲料，下午清理排泄物，这就是他真正想知道的。我几年后再见你。”
Gabe took a long drag from his cigarette and shook his head. "They won't listen," he said. "I've tried telling a few myself. But you want to go back to Earth? Go. Go back to Earth." Morgenstern hugged Gabe tightly. "Don't you have to clear it with the Chicken?" "Not the Chicken," said Gabe. "Just Chicken. And no, I don't. Chicken doesn't care either way." He flicked his cigarette butt off to the side. He gets his feed in the morning, and his droppings cleaned in the afternoon, and that's all he really wants to know. I'll see you in a couple of years."
摩根斯特恩醒了。他慢慢把头侧向一边，看到妻子和女儿汉娜正坐在医院房间的桌边吃晚餐，是鸡。“别吃，”是他唯一能勉强说出来的话。他妻子跳起来，对他突然醒来感到吃惊。“巴鲁克·海什姆（Bar Hashem），”她鼓掌道，“赞美上帝让奇迹每天发生。别摇头，扬克尔。你鼻子里有管子。汉娜，快来。你父亲活着。”
Morgenstern awoke. He rolled his head slowly to the side and saw his wife and daughter Hannah sitting at the table in the hospital room eating their dinner, chicken. "Don't eat," was all he could manage. His wife jumped, startled at his sudden awakening. "Bar Hashem," she clapped. "Blessed is the Lord who makes miracles happen every day. Don't shake your head, Yankel. You have tubes in your nose. Hannah come quick. Your father is alive."
女儿小心翼翼地走近，手里拿着一根烧烤鸡腿。“愿海什姆赐予你全面和迅速的康复，”她盯着自己的鞋子，用依地语喃喃道。她看到衬衫上有一块烧烤后的神，用手指捡起，放进嘴里。摩根斯特恩呻吟着昏了过去。
His daughter approached cautiously, holding a barbecued chicken drumstick in her hand. "May Hashem grant you a full and speedy recovery," she mumbled in Yiddish while staring at her shoes. She spotted a piece of barbecued God on her blouse, picked it off with her fingers, and popped into her mouth. Morgenstern groaned and passed out.
周五下午，他回到了自己家里的床上。他决定在出院前推迟告诉家人关于鸡的事。他今晚会在他们聚在安息日餐桌旁时告诉他们。他会告诉他们鸡的真言，他们就会被解放，也许之后会跳上车，去看电影。
Friday afternoon, he was back home in his very own bed. He had decided to put off telling his family about Chicken until he was out of the hospital. He would tell him tonight as they gathered around the Sabbath table. He would speak to them the word of Chicken, and they would be freed, maybe jump in the car afterwards, catch a movie.
当太阳终于落下，安息日终于到来，摩根斯特恩坐进轮椅，深吸一口气，推着自己进入餐厅。妻子已经铺好了精美的桌布、餐具和杯子。他看着她点亮安息日蜡烛，用手捂住脸，默默向一个不存在的神祈祷。
When the sun had finally set, and the Sabbath had finally arrived, Morgenstern pulled himself into his wheelchair, took a deep breath, and rolled himself into the dining room. His wife had set the table with the good tablecloth, the good silverware, and the good glasses. He watched her light the good Sabbath candles, covering her face with her hands and silently praying to a god who wasn't there.
“请聆听我的祝福，”她向上帝祈祷，尽管没有人在。如果她有一把谷子，也许会好些，摩根斯特恩想。也许加点苹果丁。她带着充满爱的眼神转向他。“上帝保佑，”她用依地语说。“感谢上帝。”她来到他身边，在他轮椅旁跪下，拥抱了他。“我有事要告诉你，”他说。“我知道，”她在餐巾上啜泣，“我知道。”“我想你不知道。”
"Please hear my blessings," she prayed to nobody. She'd have had better luck with a handful of scratch, thought Morgenstern. Maybe some cut up apple. She turned to him with love in her eyes. "Got tsu danken," she said in Yiddish. "Thank God." She came to him, knelt beside his wheelchair, and hugged him. "I have to tell you something," he said. "I know," she sobbed into the good napkin. "I know." "I don't think you do."
他从她身边推开。“当我死的时候，”摩根斯特恩说，“我见到了上帝。”“我们每天都能见到上帝，”妻子说，“只要我们知道往哪儿看。”“不，”摩根斯特恩惊呼，“你没听。你以为我怎么回来的？”他问她。“除了全能的慈悲者，还有谁会把你送回我身边？”她回答。他再也受不了了。“谁？”摩根斯特恩大叫，把自己推向餐桌首位，“我告诉你谁。”
He rolled away from her. "When I was dead," said Morgenstern, "I met God." "We all meet God every day," said his wife, "if only we know where to look." "No, exclaimed Morgenstern, "you're not listening. How do you think I got back here?" he asked her. "Who else but the All-Merciful would send you back to me?" She replied. He could take no more. "Who?" shouted Morgenstern as he wheeled himself around to the head of the table. "I'll tell you who."
巨大的声音吸引了孩子们。他们慢慢聚在安息日餐桌旁。“让我来告诉你们一些关于你们的全知全能。让我告诉你们一些关于你们的慈悲为怀。”摩根斯特恩从施穆尔看到约拿、迈耶、里夫卡、多维德、汉娜、迪娜、莉亚，最后是小耶切兹克尔。孩子们都洗过澡，头发梳理整齐，穿着最精致的安息日服装。他看向妻子。她戴着他最喜欢的假发。“孩子们，”他开始说。“上帝，”他说，“是，”他继续，“一只，”他补充道。
The loud voices attracted the children. And they gathered slowly around the Sabbath table. "Let me tell you a little something about your All Knowing. Let me tell you a little something about your All Merciful." Morgenstern looked from Shmuel to Yonah to Meyer to Rivka to Dovid to Hannah to Deena to Leah to little Yichezkel. The children were all showered, their hair neatly combed, and dressed in their finest Sabbath clothes. She looked at his wife. She was wearing his favorite wig. "Children," he began. "God," he said, "is," he continued, "a," he added.
安息日蜡烛的光在孩子们的眼中闪烁。小迈耶戴着崭新的小圆帽，无法停止摆弄它。施穆尔拿着拉比给他的托拉笔记，打算饭后阅读。女孩们正期待着唱她们最喜欢的安息日歌曲。“上帝是‘什么’？”小汉娜问。
The light from the Sabbath candles flickered in the eyes of his children. Little Meyer was wearing a brand new yarmulke and couldn't stop fidgeting with it. Shmuel held a handful of Torah notes from his rabbi he would read after the meal. And the girls would be looking forward to singing their favorite Sabbath songs. "God is a what?" Asked little Hannah.
他做不到。“上帝，”摩根斯特恩对孩子们说，“是一位慈悲的上帝。”妻子来到他身边。“他是我们祖先的上帝，”他继续说，“赞美上帝，他在慈悲中让死者复活。”孩子们欢呼起来。摩根斯特恩闭上眼睛，紧紧拥抱孩子们。妻子弯下腰，温柔地亲吻他的额头。“愿他的恩典永远照耀我们，”她轻声说道。她微笑着，走进厨房，端出了汤。是鸡汤。
He couldn't do it. "God," Morgenstern said to his children, "is a merciful God." His wife came to his side. "He is the God of our forefathers," he continued. "Blessed is God, who in his mercy restores life to the dead." The children cheered. Morgenstern closed his eyes and hugged his children tightly. His wife bent over and kissed him gently on his forehead. "May his kindness shine down on us forever," she whispered. She smiled then, went into the kitchen, and brought out the soup. Chicken.
沙洛姆·奥斯兰德。这个故事首次出现在他的书《小心上帝》中。
Shalom Auslander. This story first appeared in his book, "Beware of God."
我们节目今天由莎拉·科尼格和我本人制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、简·费尔特斯、丽莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞米恩、艾丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与制作。高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。PJ Vote和亚伦·斯科特提供制作协助。塞思·林德是制作经理。杰西卡·霍珀提供音乐协助。
Well our program was produced today by Sarah Koenig and myself with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from [? PJ Vote ?] and Aaron Scott. Seth Lind is our production manager. Music help from Jessica Hopper.
[鸣谢]
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。WBEZ管理层对本节目的监督由我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责。你可以说他多愁善感，说他疯狂，但每个感恩节他都做同一件事。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. And call him sentimental, call him crazy, every Thanksgiving he does the same thing.
拿起一只鸡，拔掉它的羽毛，然后放它自由。
Take a chicken, strip it of its feathers, and set it free.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American life.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。